what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today something
major happened in court for the case of
Jonathan Majors they officially released
the surveillance video from the streets
that show Jonathan majors and Grace
Jabari getting out of their private car
running down the street then the
aftermath where Grace Jabari goes to the
nightclub and then when Jonathan Majors
goes back to his apartment finds her on
the floor they also released the police
body cam footage of that as well we'll
show all of this footage in this video
it's quite interesting because you could
depict what happened here in many many
different ways the court has not ruled
on any decision yet however the trial
was said to only last about 2 weeks we
are in the second week but it could last
a third but let's go over this footage
and talk about what exactly is happening
so as the footage starts which is
provided by dailymail.com we can see
there in the back left Jonathan major is
getting out of the car he is seemingly
trying to keep Grace Jabari inside of
the car she gets out he kind of walks
away and you don't really realize what's
happening here but then eventually he
tries to break free of her hand and runs
away now don't worry they're going to
zoom in in just a bit right here we can
see Jonathan major is grabbing her
putting her into the car it looks like
she might have hit her head there that
could have been where the ear scratch
came from which allegedly came from him
assaulting her he tries to put her back
in the car now they do a slowed down and
zoomed in replay of what's Happening he
is seemingly picking her up here and she
might hit her head on top here but what
he's trying to do here is put her back
in the car it's hard to tell there if
she hits her head or not but clearly he
wants her to stay inside of the car and
he is going to eventually try to get
away like we just saw and they're going
to zoom in on that and show that as well
now obviously she is fighting trying to
get out of the car and it looks like
Jonathan major might be trying to put
her seat Bel on here try to keep her
inside the car but as you you can see
there she gets out and she goes and she
grabs his hand but as we saw he quickly
breaks their grip and he starts to run
away from her we can see in the
surveillance footage him running away
from her and she is chasing after him we
get a lot of different street angles
here a lot of different surveillance
footage here they released them all he
continues to run she continues to chase
him and then he runs across the street
now she follows after him and she just
runs right in front of this car cuts it
off she is determined to keep following
him they show us some more footage he
continues to run and it looks like she
is now slowing down a little bit she has
started to walk seems like she's
probably given up and then we see she
meets three people which were mentioned
yesterday Jabari mentioned that these
people were strangers to her she just
met them in this moment right here in
their testimonies they said that they
could tell she was upset but they didn't
notice any injuries on her now two of
these three people testified in court
Khloe Zer and Max man what happened was
which was explained in court is that
after this she met these three strangers
on the street she told them about what
happened with Jonathan majors and they
consulted her outside and after talking
they invited her to a birthday party at
Lucy's nightclub in Manhattan on the
Lower East Side and she said that she
went because she didn't want to be alone
and in court she said that she didn't
notice any of the pain she said I was
upset about the cheating it was on my
mind now one of these three people Zer
did say that they didn't notice any
injuries on her but she did complain
about her finger in the club in which
they gave her some ice for now in this
footage we can see that she is visibly
upset the people are hugging her trying
to comfort her and then Jonathan Majors
actually walks back and she tries to get
his attention she tries to talk to him
but he keeps going he says some words we
unfortunately do not have audio but he
keeps going he says something she tries
to cover her face like she's upset again
she continues to try and chase him but
it looks like he doesn't want any part
of this it then looks like he tries to
put her back inside of the private car
she doesn't want to stay inside and he
leaves we then have footage of him being
alone checking into what seems to be the
hotel that he stayed at that night then
we see footage of her at the nightclub
now we've seen this footage before we've
actually seen better footage of this it
just shows Jabari at the nightclub she
doesn't really seem to be that hurt
although it's really hard to tell of
course from surveillance footage at some
point in the footage she brushes her
hair back in which they asked her in
court if she could tell if she was
bleeding and her ear where the cut was
in which she says I didn't touch my ear
so I didn't notice any blood now here's
something that is very important to know
before we jump into the police body cam
footage it's important to know what the
driver of the private car said about
them fighting because it gives a little
bit of context the driver's name is
Navid sarir and he said this in court I
was feeling something was going on in
the back seat when I reached the canal
and Center Street Majors wanted to get
rid of Jabari and he opened the door I
saw they were fighting when the car
stopped he was trying to get rid of her
Jabari was yelling at Majors and they
were having an argument I had a feeling
Jabari had hit Majors earlier the way
she was fighting and the sounds produced
so that's what the driver said and he
didn't actually see any of the assault
take place inside of the car but he said
based off of what he heard it sounded
like she had hit him which is what
Major's team has been claiming this
entire time now the video is not very
clear when he's trying to keep her
inside of the car I'm sure it could be
interpreted both ways Majors is trying
to put her back in the car and he could
have hurt her during this moment or she
could have just assaulted him and he
wants her to stay inside of the car so
he can get away because he then runs
trying to get away from her
unfortunately even with this footage we
don't know exactly what happened but it
is interesting that Majors is the one
who ended up calling the police and we
have that footage here Majors went back
to his apartment and what is not shown
is that he supposedly had to get the
help of somebody who worked at the
apartment to open his door when he
finally went inside he found Jabari
passed out on the floor of his closet in
which he called the police we can see
him talking to the police here in the
lobby we can see the police show up and
he's even in the elevator with them and
he called the police because he was
reportedly very concerned for her and
we'll put the entire police phone call
of Jonathan major calling them at the
end of this video so you can listen to
it for yourself but we see the body cam
footage here of the police officers who
were there we can see that uh she is
covered now because she was naked from
the waist down according to Jonathan
major on the police call she's now
covered she's wearing a sweatshirt and
the officers are there helping her up
you can obviously see that she's not in
good shape she did say in court that she
took two sleeping pills before and she
was sick in this video you can clearly
tell that she is in a lot of distress
and this does of course end with
Jonathan major being arrested now again
it's really hard to say for sure what is
going on in this video clearly there is
an altercation clearly it is at least a
little bit physical as we see Jonathan
major grabbing her and trying to put her
back in the car but then then of course
we see him trying to run away from her
and she follows him for a very long time
so unfortunately we don't know exactly
what has happened and honestly the jury
could go either way with what they've
seen here based off of testimonies that
they'll hear but go ahead and let us
know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below and like I mentioned
here is the full police call that
Jonathan Major's
made medical heyo this
medical suicide I think what is the
location uh uh uh 252 Avenue all right
so that was
2527 Avenue correct yes ma'am what
apartment penth house D pen house deep
as in David right this is in Manhattan
or in Brooklyn this this
is hello sir yes ma'am this is man in
service I'm sorry okay okay it's okay
it's in Manhattan all right so this is
penth house still on the line all right
okay we'll
do David don't worry about is speaking
to me is not delaying anything I just
need some help some information for the
crew they already on the way okay
okay s let me get them going what
happened exactly do you know no I don't
know um uh but she's
unconscious um she's naked from the um
uh bottom down uh she has sweatshirt on
uh she's my ex partner um we broke up I
came back she she sent me text messages
um insinuating this much um um I stayed
in a hotel last night I came home this
morning um I banged on the door I've
been at the apartment for about 40
minutes now I bang at the door
um I couldn't get in um I finally went
downstairs and asked um the doorman to
help us and
um uh they let me in via the the
handyman all right
she's 30 years
old white
female all right does she suffer from
anything prior
to um or no she have a mental condition
on history I would maybe say so she a
history what's her name her name is
Grace Caitlyn Natasha jaar Grace all
right all right do you know what she did
or what she took or you don't know no I
don't know I just know she's she un all
right no problem sir and I'm going to
get you over to the EMS do not hang up
all right they already in Rod okay okay
all right on the line hold
[Applause]
on Arrow 639 639 I'm 2884 the job number
1749 hello co hey how are you hi this is
two to 7th Avenue of manhatt yes
sir right above the whole F okay and the
patient's breathing oh yes sir she yes
sir she is okay is she awake uh
no this is pen house Diaz and David yes
sir pen house Diaz and Dav okay you're
with her right now um I'm I've come
downstairs to let the uh Lobby men know
that um you guys are on their way so so
they're going to be there as soon as
possible um obviously what should I do
what what should I do you could just
make sure the doors open and when you
get upstairs she didn't like fall and
hit her head anything that you know of
right no I think I saw u a cut behind
her ear okay um yeah how old is she
she's 30 years old okay so if you could
just when you get back upstairs we just
want you to keep an eye on her breathing
if she wakes up we don't want to give
her anything to eat or drink like I said
they're already responding I think they
just yeah they just walked in the
through okay I think this this the amb
too the fire department I called him on
with uh uh uh got I think
that's
polio that's the police I don't know
what's she she's consci she Tred to yeah
yeah we just keep that confidence yes
sir sir you speaking to the
cops yeah I'm assuming this is f guys I
mean is it the police
um um
uh girlfriend I just back home let me
see they at the location
sorry
uh I'm leaving
take
happen yeah they at L the is at the
location okay and just to confirm again
it's 27 uh I'm sorry 2527 penous D
between 124 25th yes all right no
problem